- Willkommen zurück bei Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
Mein Name ist John Watrous, und
ich bin der Technical Director für IBM Quantum Education.
Dies ist die vierte Lektion der Reihe und gleichzeitig die letzte
Lektion der ersten Einheit der Reihe über die Grundlagen
der Quanteninformation.
Bisher haben wir besprochen,
wie Quanteninformation sowohl bei Einzel- als auch bei Mehrfachsystemen funktioniert, und wir haben uns das
Quantum-circuit-Modell angeschaut,
und wir haben einige
grundlegende Einschränkungen der Quanteninformation kennengelernt.
Dabei sind wir auf einige wichtige mathematische Konzepte
gestoßen, darunter Tensorprodukte und innere Produkte, und wir werden
diese Konzepte weiterhin nutzen und neue
einführen, sobald wir sie brauchen.
In dieser Lektion werden wir uns
auf drei grundlegende wichtige Beispiele konzentrieren: Quantenteleportation, Superdense Coding und das CHSH-Spiel,
das auch CHSH-Ungleichung genannt wird und nicht immer als Spiel beschrieben wird.
Das sind keine willkürlichen
Beispiele, die nur zeigen sollen, wie Quanteninformation funktioniert – sie sind wirklich zentrale
Bestandteile des Fundaments
der Quanteninformation und
tauchen in verschiedenen und manchmal unerwarteten Zusammenhängen innerhalb der Quanteninformation
und -berechnung auf.
Verschränkung spielt in allen drei
dieser Beispiele eine wichtige Rolle, und tatsächlich ist es die Verschränkung, die sie zum Funktionieren bringt
und sie interessant macht. Diese Lektion wird also gewissermaßen unsere erste Gelegenheit sein,
Verschränkung in Aktion zu sehen
und damit zu beginnen zu erkunden, was Verschränkung so interessant macht.
Der Überblick über die
Lektion ist sehr einfach: wir gehen nacheinander
durch die drei Beispiele, die ich gerade erwähnt habe,
Quantenteleportation,
Superdense Coding und das CHSH-Spiel.
Wir besprechen, was das alles ist und was es interessant macht, und wir führen Analysen durch, die genau erklären, wie es auf mathematischer Ebene funktioniert.
Bevor wir zum ersten
der drei Beispiele kommen, nämlich der Quantenteleportation, ist es angebracht, zunächst
die Charaktere vorzustellen,
Alice und Bob, falls du
mit ihnen noch nicht vertraut bist.
Alice und Bob sind Namen,
die hypothetischen Entitäten oder Akteuren in Systemen, Protokollen, Spielen,
und wirklich jeder anderen Art von Interaktion gegeben werden, die du dir vorstellen möchtest und die den Austausch von Informationen beinhaltet.
Sie entstammen ursprünglich dem
Bereich der Kryptographie in den 1970er Jahren, aber die
Konvention, diese Namen auf diese Weise zu verwenden, hat sich inzwischen sehr weit verbreitet
in einem viel breiteren Kontext. Die Idee dahinter ist, dass das
sehr geläufige Namen sind, zumindest in manchen Teilen der Welt, und sie beginnen mit den Buchstaben A und B,
und es ist auch praktisch,
Alice und Bob mit den Pronomen „sie" und „er" zu bezeichnen, einfach der Kürze halber.
Typischerweise stellen wir uns vor, dass Alice und Bob an verschiedenen Orten sind und dass sie unterschiedliche
Ziele und unterschiedliche Verhaltensweisen haben
je nachdem, worüber wir gerade sprechen.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel über
Kommunikation sprechen, also die Übertragung von Informationen, dann könnten wir festlegen,
dass Alice die Senderin ist
und Bob der Empfänger
der Informationen, die übermittelt werden.
Manchmal arbeiten Alice und Bob
zusammen – das ist sehr typisch –, aber manchmal stehen sie im Wettbewerb oder haben unterschiedliche Ziele, die
möglicherweise miteinander vereinbar sind oder nicht,
aber das muss alles
in der jeweiligen Situation klar gemacht werden.
Natürlich stellen sie Abstraktionen dar und nicht unbedingt echte Menschen.
Wir können auch
weitere Charaktere einführen, wie zum Beispiel Charlie und
Diane, oder andere Namen, die verschiedene
Rollen verkörpern, wie Eve
für eine Lauscherin oder Mallory für jemanden, der sich bösartig verhält,
je nach Kontext.
In jedem Fall werden wir Alice und Bob in allen drei
Beispielen sehen, die wir in dieser Lektion besprechen, und von Zeit zu Zeit
im weiteren Verlauf der Reihe. Ich werde außerdem noch ein paar
Anmerkungen zur Verschränkung machen, bevor wir zu den drei Beispielen übergehen.
In Lektion zwei begegnen wir diesem Beispiel eines verschränkten Zustands zweier Qubits.
Es ist einer der vier Bell-Zustände, und man könnte sagen, dass
dieser bestimmte Zustand das archetypische Beispiel darstellt
eines verschränkten Quantenzustands.
Wir haben auch dieses
Beispiel eines probabilistischen Zustands zweier Bits kennengelernt.
Er ist in gewisser Weise analog zum
verschränkten Zustand, aber er ist nicht verschränkt –
Verschränkung ist ein einzigartig
quantenmechanisches Phänomen,
im Wesentlichen per Definition.
Es gibt eine präzise mathematische Definition, was Verschränkung ist, und im Wesentlichen besagt diese Definition, dass Verschränkung
eine nicht-klassische Quantenkorrelation ist.
Aber das ist auf intuitiver Ebene nicht besonders
hilfreich – es ist eine Definition von Verschränkung in Bezug auf das, was Verschränkung nicht ist,
und wahrscheinlich deshalb ist es tatsächlich ziemlich schwierig zu erklären, was Verschränkung ist und was sie besonders macht,
in intuitiven Begriffen.
Wenn Leute versuchen zu
erklären, was Verschränkung in intuitiven Begriffen ist,
hört man oft Erklärungen, die diese beiden Zustände wirklich nicht
voneinander unterscheiden
auf sinnvolle Weise. Man hört vielleicht die Idee,
dass wenn man eines der beiden verschränkten Qubits misst,
sich der Zustand des anderen
irgendwie sofort beeinflusst wird oder dass der Zustand der beiden Qubits nicht separat beschrieben werden kann
oder dass die beiden Qubits
irgendwie eine Erinnerung aneinander bewahren oder sogar dass
sie auf irgendeine Weise emotional miteinander verbunden sind.
Aber warum treffen diese Eigenschaften
auf diesen Zustand nicht zu?
Diese zwei Bits sind eng miteinander verbunden, jedes hat im wörtlichen Sinne eine perfekte
Erinnerung an das andere, aber
es ist kein verschränkter Zustand.
Eine Möglichkeit zu erklären, was
Verschränkung besonders macht und was diesen Zustand
so grundlegend von jenem unterscheidet, ist zu erklären, was wir
mit Verschränkung tun können
oder was wir aufgrund von Verschränkung beobachten können, das über die Entscheidungen hinausgeht, die wir darüber treffen, wie wir unser
Wissen mit Vektoren darstellen.
Alle drei Beispiele,
die wir in dieser Lektion besprechen, haben diese Natur, indem sie
Dinge veranschaulichen, die wir mit Verschränkung tun können, die wir
mit diesem Zustand nicht tun können
oder mit irgendeinem klassisch korrelierten Zustand.
In der Tat ist es in der Quanteninformations- und Quantenberechnungsforschung sehr üblich, Verschränkung als eine Ressource zu betrachten
durch die verschiedene
Aufgaben erfüllt werden können.
Und wenn wir das tun, betrachten wir diesen Zustand als
eine Einheit der Verschränkung.
Wir bezeichnen diese Einheit der
Verschränkung als E-Bit, das E steht für
"entangled" (verschränkt) oder "entanglement" (Verschränkung).
Es stimmt, dass es zwei Qubits sind, aber als Maß der
Verschränkung ist es ein E-Bit.
Du kannst auch ein Paar
gewöhnlicher klassischer Bits im korrelierten
probabilistischen Zustand von vorhin als eine Ressource betrachten, die
ein Bit gemeinsamer Zufälligkeit darstellt.
Es kann in der
Kryptographie sehr nützlich sein, ein zufälliges Bit mit jemandem zu teilen, vorausgesetzt,
dass niemand anderes weiß, was dieses Bit ist, damit es
als privater Schlüssel verwendet werden kann
oder als Teil eines privaten Schlüssels, zum Beispiel zum Zweck der Verschlüsselung.
Aber in dieser Lektion liegt unser Fokus auf diesem verschränkten Zustand und
den Dingen, die wir damit tun können.
Und nur um die Terminologie zu klären: wenn wir sagen, dass Alice
und Bob ein E-Bit teilen, meinen wir damit, dass
Alice ein qubit namens A hat,
Bob ein qubit namens B hat, und zusammen das Paar A, B
im Phi-plus-Zustand ist.
Es ist natürlich nicht wichtig, welche Namen
wir für die beiden Qubits wählen, wir könnten
andere Namen wählen, aber in dieser Lektion
bleiben wir bei diesen Namen,
um der Klarheit willen. Das erste Beispiel der Lektion
ist Quantenteleportation,
die wir im Folgenden der Kürze halber nur noch
als Teleportation bezeichnen werden.
Teleportation ist ein Protokoll, das es einem Sender ermöglicht, Quanteninformation an einen Empfänger zu übermitteln, wobei nur Verschränkung
und klassische Kommunikation verwendet werden, um diese Übertragung zu vollziehen.
Es hat absolut nichts mit der typischen Bedeutung
des Wortes Teleportation in der Science-Fiction zu tun, wonach
Materie verschwindet
an einem Ort und an einem anderen erscheint.
Quantenteleportation ist nur ein Name, der dieses Bild oder diese Metapher heraufbeschwören soll, sozusagen.
Was teleportiert wird, ist
Quanteninformation, nicht Materie, und das geschieht
durch eine Übertragung klassischer Information
zusammen mit Verschränkung.
Um genau zu verstehen,
wie Teleportation funktioniert, ist es hilfreich, zunächst
den Rahmen abzustecken, sozusagen.
Was wir tun werden, ist uns ein Szenario mit Alice und Bob vorzustellen, und
dieses Szenario ist wie folgt:
Alice hat ein qubit namens Q, das
sie an Bob übermitteln möchte, das heißt, sie möchte, dass Bob in seinen Händen hält
ein qubit, das sich in genau
demselben Zustand befindet, in dem Q sich zu Beginn des Protokolls befindet.
Mit anderen Worten sprechen wir über das grundlegende Problem der
Informationsübertragung oder Kommunikation.
Wir haben einen Sender namens Alice
und einen Empfänger namens Bob, und Alice möchte
Quanteninformation in Form eines qubit an Bob senden.
Es gibt jedoch eine Einschränkung, nämlich dass Alice
Q nicht physisch an Bob senden kann; alles, was sie tun kann, ist, klassische Information an Bob zu senden.
Alice und Bob haben außerdem
eine zusätzliche Ressource, nämlich dass sie ein E-Bit teilen.
Das ist also das Szenario. Es ist
leicht, sich Situationen vorzustellen, in denen die Einschränkung, dass
Alice Q nicht physisch senden kann,
eine vernünftige Abstraktion ist.
Wenn Alice und Bob sich auf
verschiedenen Kontinenten befänden zum Beispiel, oder wenn Alice
Bobs genauen Aufenthaltsort nicht kennen würde, dann wäre das physische Senden eines qubit
wahrscheinlich ziemlich schwierig.
Aber klassische Kommunikation
ist natürlich unter diesen Umständen nicht nur möglich, sondern auch ziemlich kostengünstig.
Nun könnte man fragen, ob es möglich wäre, dass Alice und Bob diese Aufgabe auch ohne das gemeinsame E-Bit bewältigen.
Mit anderen Worten: Gibt es
eine Möglichkeit, ein qubit allein durch klassische
Kommunikation zu übertragen?
Die Antwort ist nein, es ist nicht möglich, Quanteninformation allein durch klassische Kommunikation zu übertragen, und das ist nicht allzu schwer zu beweisen
mithilfe einiger grundlegender Quanteninformationstheorie, die wir in der
dritten Einheit der Serie sehen werden.
Vorerst ist eine intuitive
Möglichkeit, darüber nachzudenken, das No-Cloning-Theorem.
Stell dir vor, es gäbe einen Weg,
Quanteninformationen allein über klassische Kommunikation zu übertragen,
aber klassische Kommunikation
lässt sich leicht kopieren und verbreiten, das bedeutet also,
dass die klassische Kommunikation
an zwei Empfänger gesendet werden könnte,
sagen wir Bob und Charlie.
Wenn beide dieselbe klassische
Information von Alice empfangen hätten,
würden sie dann beide mit Q enden?
Das würde bedeuten, dass wir Q geklont haben, aber wir wissen, dass das unmöglich ist.
Nebenbei bemerkt: Lass uns
feststellen, dass es durchaus möglich ist,
Quantenzustandsvektoren mithilfe klassischer Informationen zu beschreiben.
Jeder Quantenzustandsvektor,
den du in der Serie sehen wirst, wird dir
mithilfe klassischer Informationen beschrieben,
die an das Gerät übertragen wurden, auf dem du schaust.
Grundsätzlich könnten wir uns vorstellen,
welchen Zustand Q auch immer hat,
mit klassischen Bits zu beschreiben –
vielleicht mit einer gewissen Genauigkeit,
aber das ist keine Quantenkommunikation,
das ist nur das Beschreiben von Quantenzuständen als Vektoren,
und wir werden auf den
Unterschied zwischen ihnen zurückkommen
in einem Moment.
Zurück zu dem Szenario jedoch:
Unter der Annahme, dass Alice und Bob
ein e-Bit teilen, werden wir sehen,
dass Alice und Bob
alles haben, was sie brauchen,
um die Aufgabe zu erfüllen, und genau das tut
das Quantenteleportationsprotokoll –
und zwar mit genau zwei Bits
klassischer Kommunikation.
Bevor wir auf
diese Details eingehen, lass mich jedoch
ein paar kurze Anmerkungen machen,
um sicherzustellen, dass die Annahmen klar sind.
Erstens nehmen wir hier an,
dass der Zustand von Q
Alice und Bob unbekannt ist,
insbesondere also,
dass Alice Bob keine
Beschreibung des Zustands Q schicken kann,
weil sie ihn im Allgemeinen nicht kennt.
Wir müssen auch die Möglichkeit in Betracht ziehen,
dass Q mit anderen Systemen korreliert ist,
einschließlich der Möglichkeit, dass es verschränkt ist
mit anderen Systemen, und die
Übertragung dieses qubit an Bob
muss diese Korrelationen erhalten.
Abschließend habe ich das No-Cloning-Theorem erwähnt,
als ich davon sprach, Qubits klassisch zu kommunizieren,
aber es gibt noch eine weitere Verbindung hier
mit dem No-Cloning-Theorem:
Wenn Bob die Übertragung
dieses qubit Q von Alice empfängt,
dann darf sie es nicht mehr haben,
weil Q nicht geklont werden kann –
das ist etwas, das man im Hinterkopf behalten sollte,
wenn wir das Teleportationsprotokoll betrachten.
Das Teleportationsprotokoll
lässt sich auf eine ziemlich einfache und direkte Weise
mit dem Quantencircuit-Diagramm beschreiben,
wie du hier sehen kannst.
Es ist leicht stilisiert, da es die
Trennung zwischen Alices Teil und Bobs Teil darstellt,
aber ansonsten ist es
nur ein Quantencircuit-Diagramm,
alles oberhalb der gestrichelten Linie
stellt Alices Aktionen dar und
alles darunter stellt
Bobs Aktionen dar.
Die Zeit verläuft wie immer von links nach rechts,
und wir sehen, dass wir mit diesen
zwei Qubits beginnen, die sich im Phi-plus-Zustand befinden –
das ist also das e-Bit
mit dem Alice und Bob beginnen.
Wir können die Qubits beschriften, um
klarzumachen, welches welches ist –
das ist also das qubit A und das ist das qubit
B, die zusammen das e-Bit bilden,
und das ist das qubit Q, das
Alice an Bob übertragen möchte.
Hier nehmen wir hypothetisch an, dass
der Zustand dieses qubit Q gleich Psi ist,
aber etwas später werden wir
die Möglichkeit in Betracht ziehen, dass Q verschränkt ist
mit einem anderen System. Und was das Diagramm aussagt,
weil wir Psi hier unten geschrieben haben,
ist, dass dieser circuit
tatsächlich jeden Zustand Psi überträgt,
den wir hier oben auf Alices Seite hatten,
hier unten zu Bobs Seite –
die einzige Kommunikation,
die die Linie zwischen
Alice und Bob überquert, sind die zwei klassischen
Bits, die durch diese doppelten Linien hier dargestellt werden.
Lass uns dieses Diagramm ein
bisschen verkleinern, damit wir
etwas mehr Platz haben,
und den circuit genauer betrachten.
Ich habe die Ausgangsbedingungen bereits beschrieben,
aber um es kurz zusammenzufassen:
Alice hält ein qubit A
und Bob hält ein qubit B,
wobei A und B zusammen
im Phi-plus-Zustand sind –
das ist also das, was es bedeutet, ein e-Bit zu teilen.
Alice hat auch dieses qubit Q, das sie an Bob übertragen möchte, und wir betrachten den Fall, dass Q sich in einem beliebigen Quantenzustand Psi befindet.
Wir wissen nichts darüber,
wie Alice und Bob in den Besitz
dieses e-Bits gekommen sind.
Es könnte sein, dass sie es
schon lange haben –
vielleicht haben sie es vor einiger Zeit erstellt,
als sie sich am selben Ort befanden,
und sie haben es für diesen Anlass aufgespart,
aber diese Details sind hier nicht relevant.
Die nächsten Schritte, die das
Teleportationsprotokoll selbst darstellen,
sind wie folgt – und nur damit das klar ist:
Das sind die Schritte, die
das Diagramm beschreibt, und wir werden sie
nur in Worten festhalten,
damit klar ist, was das Diagramm ausdrückt.
Alice führt zunächst eine
kontrollierte-NICHT-Operation durch, bei der das qubit Q,
das sie an Bob senden möchte, das Steuerelement ist
und das qubit A das Ziel ist.
Der nächste Schritt ist, dass sie eine
Hadamard-Operation auf Q anwendet,
und dann misst sie die zwei Qubits, die sie hält,
A und Q, bezüglich
Standardbasismessungen, und wir bezeichnen
Kleinbuchstabe a als Ergebnis der Messung
des qubit A,
und wir bezeichnen Kleinbuchstabe b als Ergebnis der Messung des qubit Q.
Alice sendet dann diese
zwei klassischen Bits an Bob –
das ist die einzige Kommunikation,
die in diesem Protokoll vorkommt,
und das ist im Diagramm angezeigt
durch die Tatsache, dass diese zwei
Bits die gestrichelte Linie zwischen Alice und Bob überqueren,
was du dir als Darstellung
der Entfernung vorstellen kannst, die sie voneinander trennt.
Nachdem Bob die Bits
a und b empfangen hat, tut er zwei Dinge.
Erstens: Wenn a gleich eins ist, führt er eine X-Operation
aus – mit anderen Worten ein NOT gate auf seinem qubit B,
und andernfalls, wenn a gleich null ist, tut er das nicht.
Und in ähnlicher Weise gilt:
Wenn b gleich eins ist, führt Bob eine Z-Operation
oder ein Z-gate oder einen Phasenflip aus
ebenfalls auf dem qubit b, und wie
zuvor: Wenn b gleich null ist, tut er das nicht.
Das ist alles in der Abbildung angegeben, wo wir diese controlled-X-
und controlled-Z-gates haben, bei denen die Steuersignale
die zwei klassischen Bits sind.
Du musst diese gates nicht als Steuer-gates betrachten,
wenn du das nicht möchtest – das ist nur eine praktische Weise,
auszudrücken, was wir wollen,
in Form eines circuit-Diagramms. Der Punkt ist, dass Bob
ein X-gate auf das qubit b anwendet, wenn a gleich eins ist, und
dann wendet er ein Z-gate an
auf das qubit b, wenn B gleich eins ist.
Und der Einfachheit halber können wir später explizit
die kombinierte Operation aufschreiben, die Bob auf seinem qubit b ausführt,
abhängig von den klassischen
Bits, die Alice sendet.
Das ist also das Teleportationsprotokoll – es ist eigentlich ziemlich einfach.
Die Tatsache, dass es tatsächlich funktioniert, ist eine andere Sache,
und obwohl die Analyse
nicht besonders kompliziert ist,
solltest du dich nicht schlecht fühlen, wenn du nicht sofort siehst, warum es funktioniert.
Deshalb müssen wir
eine Analyse durchführen, und das ist das, was wir als Nächstes tun werden.
Um das Teleportationsprotokoll zu analysieren, arbeiten wir es Schritt für Schritt durch,
um zu sehen, in welchen Zuständen die drei Qubits sich zu verschiedenen Zeitpunkten befinden.
Wir betrachten zunächst
den Fall, dass das oberste qubit im Zustand AlphaNull plus Beta eins ist, wobei Alpha und Beta
beliebige komplexe Zahlen sind,
die dafür sorgen, dass dieser Vektor
ein Einheitsvektor ist.
Das ist das qubit Q, das
Alice zu übertragen versucht, aber wie es heißt, ist uns in diesem Moment eigentlich egal.
Etwas später werden wir
uns die Situation ansehen, in der dieses qubit mit einem anderen System verschränkt ist,
aber das ist ein guter Ausgangspunkt, um die Dinge einfach zu halten
und um zu sehen, wie die Analyse
etwas klarer funktioniert.
Wenn wir den Zustand der
drei Qubits hier zusammen am Anfang betrachten, sehen wir,
dass dieser Zustand die Form hat, die du hier siehst.
Die ersten zwei Qubits befinden sich
im Phi-plus-Zustand, das dritte qubit ist das oberste
gemäß der Konvention
für die Anordnung von Qubits, die ich
in der vorherigen Lektion beschrieben habe, und so nehmen wir das Tensorprodukt, um den Zustand der
drei Qubits zusammen zu erhalten.
Wir können diesen Ausdruck erweitern,
indem wir zunächst die Definition des Phi-plus-Zustands einsetzen und dann das Tensorprodukt berechnen
und wir erhalten den Zustand,
den du hier siehst.
Es ist übrigens nicht immer
die beste Strategie, einen Vektor wie diesen vollständig zu entfalten –
es ist generell eine gute Idee zu warten, bis
du einen guten Grund hast, das zu tun.
Aber hier haben wir einen Grund, nämlich dass wir
die Wirkung dieses controlled-NOT-gates berechnen möchten, und indem wir den Zustand in dieser Form schreiben,
können wir das sehr leicht tun.
Und insbesondere ist das
der Zustand der drei Qubits nachdem das controlled-NOT-gate angewendet wurde.
Das dritte qubit ist das Steuer-qubit, weil das nach
unserer Konvention das oberste ist, und das zweite qubit,
also das mittlere,
ist das Ziel-qubit, also wirken wir
auf die Kets entsprechend: Wenn das dritte Bit null ist,
passiert nichts,
und wenn das dritte Bit eins ist,
dann flippen wir das zweite Bit.
Dann wenden wir das Hadamard
gate auf das dritte qubit an, und wir können den resultierenden
Vektor so schreiben, wie du es sehen kannst
hier, indem wir den
Plus- und den Minus-Zustand für den Null- und den Eins-Zustand einsetzen.
Und wenn wir genug Platz haben wollen,
um diesen hier zu entfalten, müssen wir ihn etwas verkleinern,
und nun, indem wir den Plus- und den Minus-Zustand
durch ihre Definitionen ersetzen
und die Quadratwurzel aus zwei in den Nenner bringen, erhalten wir den Zustand, den du hier siehst.
Und indem wir den hier entfalten, erhalten wir den Zustand, den du hier siehst.
Das ist also der Zustand der drei Qubits, nachdem Alice ihre zwei Operationen ausgeführt hat.
Alice misst dann,
und wenn wir die Messungen analysieren wollen, isolieren wir die Standardbasisvektoren
für die zu messenden Systeme,
genau wie wir in Lektion zwei besprochen haben, und wenn wir das in diesem konkreten Fall tun, ist das das, was wir erhalten.
Und wenn du dir diesen
Ausdruck einen Moment lang ansiehst, könnte er etwas eigenartig wirken, weil es jetzt so aussieht, als würde das erste qubit,
also das unterste qubit,
irgendwie von Alpha und Beta abhängen, obwohl
es zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch keine Kommunikation über die gestrichelte Linie gegeben hat,
aber das ist nur eine Illusion. Denk daran, dass skalare Faktoren
frei durch Tensorprodukte gleiten, sodass es wirklich keinen Sinn gibt,
in dem Alpha und Beta
mit dem ersten qubit verbunden sind.
Wir haben hier im Grunde nur
Klammern entsprechend der
Multilinearität von Tensorprodukten verwendet.
Das ist jedenfalls die Form, die wir brauchen, um zu sehen, was die Messung bewirkt, und wir können sofort eine
interessante Sache erkennen
und zwar, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeiten der vier möglichen Messergebnisse stets gleichmäßig verteilt sind.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, jedes
Paar von Messergebnissen zu messen, beträgt ein Viertel, also insbesondere
gibt es keinerlei Abhängigkeit
von alpha und beta.
Das können wir in jedem Fall erkennen, indem wir die quadrierte euklidische Norm
des Vektors berechnen, der mit dem isolierten Standardbasisvektor
tensored wird,
und in jedem Fall haben wir ein Viertel, das wir erhalten, indem wir ein Halb quadrieren mal dem Betragsquadrat von alpha
plus dem Betragsquadrat
von beta, was eins ist, und so erhalten wir in jedem Fall ein Viertel.
Es ist tatsächlich sehr wichtig,
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeiten dieser verschiedenen Ergebnisse in keiner Weise von dem qubit abhängen, das
Alice übertragen möchte.
Es könnte nicht sein, dass ein beliebiger Zustand hier oben hineinkommt und hier unten herauskommt und eine Messung dabei
Informationen über diesen Zustand preisgibt.
Wenn du Informationen über einen beliebigen Quantenzustand gewinnen möchtest, wirst du diesen
Zustand im Allgemeinen stören müssen.
Hier ist eine Tabelle, die nicht nur die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
der verschiedenen Ergebnisse beschreibt, sondern auch den Zustand der
drei qubits zusammen
bedingt auf jedes mögliche
Messergebnis.
Wir erhalten dies, indem wir die Vektoren normieren, die mit den verschiedenen
Standardbasiszuständen tensored werden, aber das ist in diesem Fall einfach,
wir eliminieren einfach den Faktor ein Halb, um einen Einheitsvektor zu erhalten.
Was wir also unmittelbar nach
Alices Messung haben, ist, dass Alice zwei gleichmäßig
verteilte zufällige Bits hat und das war's.
Insbesondere hat sie den ursprünglichen Zustand nicht mehr
und sie hat auch keine
Informationen darüber, sie hat nur zufällige Bits.
Bobs Zustand hängt nun
von alpha und beta sowie von den Messergebnissen ab.
Wenn wir uns momentan vorstellen,
dass Alice die Messergebnisse noch nicht übermittelt hat,
sodass Bob die Messergebnisse nicht kennt,
dann wäre er nicht in der Lage,
irgendwelche Informationen über alpha und beta
durch Messen seines qubit zu gewinnen.
Diese vier Möglichkeiten,
die wir hier haben, sind ausreichend verschlüsselt, um sicherzustellen, dass keine Informationen
über alpha und beta
jemals durch eine Messung gewonnen werden könnten. Das muss auf intuitiver Ebene wahr sein, denn sonst hätten wir
schnellere-als-Licht-Kommunikation.
Alice kann sicherlich keine
Informationen an Bob übermitteln, ohne überhaupt etwas zu senden, aber natürlich sendet Alice
die Messergebnisse
an Bob, also erweitern wir die Tabelle, um zu sehen, was passiert, wenn
Bob seine Operationen durchführt.
In dieser Spalte hier haben wir die verschiedenen Operationen, die Bob effektiv für jedes der möglichen
Ergebnisse der Messungen durchführt
wie wir zuvor beobachtet haben,
und wenn wir Schritt für Schritt gehen und diese
Operation auf Bobs qubit anwenden, das das erste ist, B,
sehen wir, dass wir in allen vier Fällen dasselbe
Ergebnis erhalten, und dieses Ergebnis ist der ursprüngliche Zustand.
Der ursprüngliche Zustand des qubit Q wurde also erfolgreich in B teleportiert.
Wenn Bob sein qubit an diesem Punkt umbenennen und Q nennen möchte, steht ihm das natürlich frei, aber der Punkt ist, dass er jetzt
den ursprünglichen Zustand hält
den Alice hatte, und natürlich hat Alice ihn notwendigerweise nicht mehr.
Beachte auch, dass das e-Bit
durch diesen Prozess effektiv verbraucht wurde,
Teleportation hat einen Preis
und der Preis beträgt ein e-Bit und zwei klassische Kommunikationsbits, und wenn das Protokoll
vorbei ist, ist das e-Bit verschwunden.
Wir haben nun festgestellt, dass
das Teleportationsprotokoll korrekt funktioniert, unter der Annahme, dass das oberste qubit in einem Quantenzustand ist
der Form alpha mal ket
null plus beta mal ket eins.
Aber was passiert, wenn das
oberste qubit mit einem anderen System verschränkt ist, wie
einem unserer zusätzlichen qubits
wie wir es hier auf dem Bildschirm haben? Wir möchten möglicherweise Teleportation
unter solchen Umständen verwenden.
Vielleicht planen Alice und Bob tatsächlich, die Teleportation 100 Mal durchzuführen, damit Alice
ein 100 qubit Quantenregister
an Bob übertragen kann, ein qubit nach dem anderen.
Oder vielleicht befinden sich diese zusätzlichen
qubits gar nicht in Alices Besitz
und jemand anderes hat sie, vielleicht weiß Alice nicht einmal,
dass sie existieren.
Die Frage ist, funktioniert
die Teleportation noch, auch wenn das zu teleportierende qubit mit einem anderen System verschränkt ist?
Hier wird der Zustand des qubit Q zusammen mit dem betrachteten zusätzlichen
System so ausgedrückt, wie du es hier oben sehen kannst
wobei gamma null und
gamma eins Einheitsvektoren sind, die Quantenzustände
dieses zusätzlichen Systems darstellen.
Wir können einen beliebigen Zustand des kombinierten Systems immer auf diese Weise schreiben.
Wir brauchen eigentlich nicht einmal
alpha und beta hier, aber wenn wir sie einschließen,
können wir gamma null und gamma eins als Einheitsvektoren nehmen
und das wird die
Verbindung zum einfacheren Fall, den wir bereits betrachtet haben, transparenter machen.
Wir können eine
ähnliche Analyse wie die durchführen, die wir bereits durchgeführt haben, aber dabei auch dieses zusätzliche System im Blick behalten.
Es ist ein wenig unübersichtlicher, weil wir das zusätzliche System haben, aber
die Idee ist genau dieselbe, hier ist eine sehr kurze Zusammenfassung.
Das ist der Anfangszustand, hier ist der Zustand nach
dem kontrollierten NOT gate,
und hier ist der Zustand nach
der Hadamard-Operation.
Wenn wir diese Dinge
auseinandernehmen, können wir diesen Zustand ausdrücken, wie du hier siehst,
das ist der Zustand unmittelbar
vor Alices Messungen, und wenn wir die
Möglichkeiten wie zuvor durchgehen
und wir betrachten, was
passiert, wenn Bob welche Operation auch immer er anwenden soll anwendet,
dann stellen wir fest, dass tatsächlich
der korrekte Zustand herauskommt und das Protokoll wie erwartet funktioniert.
In dieser Tabelle verwenden wir übrigens den Buchstaben R, um
auf dieses zusätzliche System zu verweisen, und du kannst sehen, dass wir
einen ziemlich einfachen Trick verwenden,
nämlich zu entscheiden, dass wir es vorziehen, zumindest vorübergehend, die
Systeme als B, R, A, Q zu ordnen
weil das praktischer ist, um die Zustände hier aufzuschreiben.
Gemäß dem Diagramm sollten die Systeme als
B, A, Q, R geordnet sein,
aber solange wir es klar machen, können wir eine andere
Reihenfolge wählen, die praktischer ist.
Kurz gesagt, alles was in dieser Analyse passiert, ist
dasselbe wie in der einfacheren Analyse,
aber wir haben zufällig
diese zusätzlichen Vektoren, gamma zero und gamma one,
die im Grunde mitfahren.
Wir haben immer gamma zero,
wenn es einen Faktor alpha gibt, und gamma one, wenn
es einen Faktor beta gibt, und am Ende des Tages
geht alles korrekt auf.
Das ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht überraschend, wir haben einen physikalischen Prozess, der wie die Identitäts-
operation auf einem qubit wirkt
in einem beliebigen Quantenzustand, und es gibt nur eine
Möglichkeit, wie das passieren kann, und das ist, dass die Operation
die Identitätsoperation ist.
Das ist etwas einfacher zu erklären mit der allgemeinen Formulierung
der Quanteninformation, aber der Punkt ist, dass durch Linearität,
wir diese zusätzliche Analyse eigentlich gar nicht durchgehen mussten.
Sobald wir wissen, dass
Teleportation für ein einzelnes qubit in Isolation korrekt funktioniert, können wir schlussfolgern, dass es
nur eine mögliche Sache gibt
die beschreiben kann, was das Protokoll tut, und das ist, dass es
die Identitätsoperation implementiert, bei der ein qubit hier reinkommt
und hier rauskommt, und dabei effektiv als ein perfekter,
rauschfreier Quantenkanal wirkt.
Nur ein paar kurze Anmerkungen
zur Teleportation, bevor wir zum
zweiten Beispiel der Lektion übergehen, dem Superdense Coding.
Erstens denke ich, es ist wichtig klarzustellen, dass Teleportation keine Anwendung von Quanteninformation ist, sondern ein Protokoll
und insbesondere ist es ein
Protokoll zur Durchführung von Quantenkommunikation.
Damit Teleportation,
wie ich sie beschrieben habe, nützlich ist, muss es einen Grund geben, Quantenkommunikation durchzuführen.
Zweitens ist es vernünftig zu spekulieren, dass Teleportation eines
Tages zu einem Standardverfahren werden könnte
um Quanteninformation zu übertragen, und insbesondere könnte ein Prozess, der als Entanglement-Destillation bekannt ist,
potenziell verwendet werden
als eine Möglichkeit, Qubits zuverlässig zu übertragen. Wenn Alice und Bob wissen, dass sie
Quanteninformation übertragen werden, oder sie
die Notwendigkeit haben, zu übertragen,
könnte dieser Prozess der Entanglement-Destillation
verwendet werden, um eine größere Anzahl von verrauschten E-Bits zu konvertieren
in eine kleinere Anzahl
von hochwertigen E-Bits, die dann für rauschfreie oder nahezu rauschfreie Teleportation genutzt werden könnten.
Die Idee ist, dass der Prozess
der Entanglement-Destillation in gewissem Sinne nicht so empfindlich ist, wir könnten Verluste akzeptieren und
wenn es nicht klappt,
könnten wir es einfach noch einmal versuchen, wohingegen die eigentlichen Qubits, die
wir übertragen möchten, als viel kostbarer betrachtet werden könnten.
Natürlich ist das alles Spekulation, aber der Punkt ist, dass es nicht schwer ist, Situationen zu hypothetisieren,
in denen Teleportation
eine sehr praktische
Möglichkeit sein könnte, Qubits zu übertragen.
Und der letzte Punkt
bezüglich der Teleportation ist, dass die Idee hinter der Teleportation und die Art, wie sie funktioniert,
sehr grundlegend ist
in der Quanteninformation und -berechnung, Teleportation ist wirklich ein Grundstein der Quanteninformationstheorie und Variationen
der Idee tauchen auch oft
auf, das ist nur ein Beispiel, es gibt Vorschläge zur
Implementierung verschiedener quantum gates
mittels Teleportation, aber
bei denen verschiedene Anfangszustände und Messungen gewählt werden, sodass das Ergebnis
darin besteht, eine gewählte Operation
anzuwenden, anstatt zu kommunizieren.
Das nächste Beispiel ist Superdense Coding.
Wie die Quantenteleportation
ist Superdense Coding ein Protokoll, und was es erreicht, ist komplementär zur Teleportation.
Während Teleportation es ermöglicht,
ein qubit mithilfe eines E-Bits und zwei
klassischen Kommunikationsbits zu übertragen,
ermöglicht Superdense Coding
die Übertragung von zwei klassischen Bits mithilfe
eines E-Bits und eines qubits an Quantenkommunikation.
Kurz gesagt ermöglicht Superdense Coding die Übertragung
von klassischer Information, und der Grund, warum es
Superdense Coding genannt wird,
ist, dass es ermöglicht, zwei
klassische Kommunikationsbits in ein einzelnes qubit zu packen,
aber wir müssen dafür ein
E-Bit aufwenden.
Hier ist eine genauere
Erklärung des Setups.
Wieder haben wir Alice und Bob, wobei Alice die Senderin
ist und Bob der Empfänger, und diesmal hat Alice zwei klassische Bits,
die sie an Bob senden möchte.
Alice kann Bob ein einzelnes qubit senden, und Alice und Bob teilen
sich ein e-Bit, das sie nutzen können, um ihre Aufgabe zu erfüllen,
nämlich dass Bob
die zwei klassischen Bits empfängt.
Diese Aufgabe mag in gewissem Sinne weniger interessant erscheinen als das, was
Teleportation leistet,
besonders wenn man davon ausgeht,
dass das Senden von qubits deutlich schwieriger
oder anspruchsvoller ist als das Senden klassischer Bits –
was ein ziemlich vernünftiger Standpunkt ist –, aber es ist definitiv interessant, dass das möglich ist.
Ein Grund, warum es interessant ist,
liegt darin, dass es tatsächlich unmöglich ist,
diese Aufgabe der Übertragung von zwei klassischen Bits an Information
mit einem einzelnen qubit zu erfüllen,
ohne das e-Bit zu verwenden.
Das wissen wir aufgrund eines bekannten Theorems, das als Holevos Theorem bekannt ist.
Holevos Theorem ist
allgemeiner als das, und die genaue Aussage
von Holevos Theorem ist etwas technisch und
erfordert etwas Erklärung,
aber eine seiner Implikationen
ist, dass du keine beliebige Anzahl klassischer
Bits allein mit weniger qubits
an Quantenkommunikation übertragen kannst.
Wenn du zuverlässig zwei klassische Bits an
Information mit qubits übertragen möchtest und kein
e-Bit zur Verfügung hast,
musst du zwei qubits senden – dann könnten sie genauso gut die Bits speichern, die du übertragen möchtest.
Ein weiterer Grund, warum Superdense
Coding interessant ist, liegt in der engen
komplementären Beziehung zur Teleportation – dazu kommen wir
etwas später zurück. Hier ist eine quantum circuit-Beschreibung des Superdense-Coding-Protokolls.
Bei diesem werde ich
nicht alle Schritte auflisten, sondern wir bleiben einfach bei der circuit-Diagramm-Beschreibung.
Wie du sehen kannst, haben wir wieder
Alice und Bob, wobei Alice oben
und Bob unten ist.
Hier ist das e-Bit, das
anfänglich zwischen Alice und Bob geteilt wird, und das
irgendwie vor dem Ausführen des Protokolls eingerichtet wurde.
Alice hat zwei klassische Bits, A und B, die du hier oben sehen kannst,
und durch das Protokoll, das der circuit beschreibt,
landen diese zwei klassischen Bits
schließlich bei Bob.
Es gibt nur ein qubit,
das die Grenze zwischen Alice und Bob überquert, und natürlich werden
keine klassischen Bits gesendet –
die Übertragung
der zwei klassischen Bits ist der Sinn des Protokolls.
Du wirst auch bemerken, dass es
genau dieselben Komponenten wie bei der Teleportation verwendet: wir haben ein kontrolliertes NOT-
gate, ein Hadamard-gate,
sowie ein Z- und ein X-gate,
gesteuert durch klassische Bits.
Sie sind jedoch anders angeordnet, also gehen wir zur
Analyse über, um zu sehen, wie es funktioniert.
Um zu analysieren, wie Superdense Coding funktioniert, beginnen wir damit,
die Bell-Basis aufzuschreiben, die wirklich im
Mittelpunkt der Analyse steht.
Was wir tun werden, ist
zunächst einen Blick auf den Effekt zu werfen, den Alices Aktionen
auf den Phi-plus-Zustand haben, und wir werden sehen, dass Alice diesen
Phi-plus-Zustand in einen
der vier Bell-Zustände transformiert, je nach den Bits,
die sie senden möchte.
Also schreiben wir eine Tabelle auf, damit wir
den Überblick behalten können.
Wenn A und B beide null sind, wird weder das Z-gate noch
das X-gate angewendet, also bewirken Alices Aktionen nichts –
das heißt, Phi-plus
wird auf Phi-plus abgebildet.
Wir können das auch als Gleichung ausdrücken, wie du hier siehst:
mit Alices qubit passiert nichts und mit Bobs qubit passiert nichts,
und nichts zu tun wird
durch die Identitätsmatrix dargestellt.
Was passiert nun, wenn A gleich null und B gleich eins ist?
Da B gleich eins ist, wenden wir das Z-gate an,
und das X-gate wenden wir nicht an, weil A gleich null ist –
und wir sehen, dass der Gesamteffekt darin besteht, dass Alice ein Z-gate ausführt.
Alice ist auf der rechten Seite,
weil sie oben ist, obwohl das in diesem speziellen
Fall keinen Unterschied machen würde – der Effekt ist,
dass der Phi-plus-Zustand
auf Phi-minus abgebildet wird, was du aus diesen Ausdrücken erkennen kannst, wenn du dich daran erinnerst, wie ein Z-gate funktioniert.
Wir können diesen Fall in unsere Tabelle aufnehmen; es gibt noch zwei weitere Fälle: wenn A gleich eins
und B gleich null ist,
führt Alice ein
X-gate aus, das Phi in Chi-plus überführt, und wenn A gleich eins
und B gleich eins ist,
führt Alice erst Z, dann
X aus, und wir erhalten Chi-minus.
Unsere Tabelle zeigt uns also, was in den vier möglichen Fällen passiert – nämlich, dass Alice effektiv auswählt, welchen
der vier Bell-Zustände sie
mit Bob teilen möchte, und sie hat die Freiheit zu wählen, indem sie allein auf ihr qubit einwirkt –
und das ist ein ziemlich interessanter
Aspekt der Verschränkung.
Alice sendet dann ihr qubit
an Bob; zu diesem Zeitpunkt hält Bob einen der vier Bell-Zustände und muss nur noch
herausfinden, welcher es ist,
um die Bits zu rekonstruieren.
Und wir können überprüfen, dass
tatsächlich ein kontrolliertes NOT-gate, gefolgt von einem Hadamard-gate,
wie wir es im Diagramm haben, das Richtige tut.
Ich werde sie nicht im Detail durchgehen, aber wenn du das tust, wirst du feststellen, dass die Wirkung
so ist, wie du sie hier in der Tabelle siehst.
Eine Möglichkeit, das zu überprüfen,
besteht einfach darin, es zu berechnen. Alternativ können wir erkennen, dass wir das eigentlich bereits
in umgekehrter Reihenfolge durchgegangen sind
in der vorherigen Lektion. In der vorherigen Lektion hatten wir
das Hadamard-gate zuerst und das kontrollierte NOT-gate als zweites
und wir haben gesehen, dass dieses circuit
Standardbasiszustände auf Bell-Zustände abbildet, mit einem lästigen
Minuszeichen in einem der Fälle.
Wenn wir die Reihenfolge der gates umkehren und die Tatsache berücksichtigen,
dass beide dieser zwei gates ihre eigenen Inversen sind,
erhalten wir das Inverse,
und so ist es in diesem
Fall so, dass die Wirkung in die entgegengesetzte Richtung geht
und das Minuszeichen sich aussuchen kann, auf welcher
Seite es sein möchte,
aber ansonsten ist es dort, wo es hingehört, und an diesem Punkt ist es
unmittelbar klar, dass die Messung die richtigen Werte offenbart,
das Minuszeichen hier stört uns nicht, weil eins mit
Wahrscheinlichkeit eins in diesem Fall auftritt, und das ist alles zur Analyse.
Kurz gesagt, Alice wählt einen Bell-Zustand und Bob findet heraus, welcher es ist.
Nur ein paar kurze Anmerkungen
zum Superdense Coding, bevor wir weitermachen; zunächst sollten wir anerkennen,
dass Superdense Coding
wahrscheinlich nicht
nützlich oder praktisch in irgendeinem Sinne als Mittel zur
Übertragung klassischer Information sein wird.
Klassische Kommunikation
ist sehr kostengünstig und Qubits physisch zu senden ist, gelinde gesagt, eine Herausforderung,
und solange das der Fall ist, würden wir keinen
praktischen Vorteil durch Superdense Coding erwarten.
Aber nur weil es
wahrscheinlich nicht praktisch ist, bedeutet das nicht, dass Superdense
Coding nicht interessant ist.
Es ist tatsächlich sehr interessant; unter anderem ist die zugrunde liegende Idee
wirklich ziemlich grundlegend,
und wenn ich mich auf die zugrunde liegende Idee beziehe, meine ich die Idee, dass wenn Alice
einen Bell-Zustand mit Bob teilt,
sie dann diesen Zustand in jeden anderen Bell-Zustand ihrer Wahl
ganz alleine ändern kann, sie braucht Bobs
Hilfe dafür überhaupt nicht.
Dies ist ein spezifisches Beispiel,
das die Bell-Zustände betrifft, aber es gibt eine allgemeinere zugrunde liegende Idee, die die Freiheit betrifft, die ein Spieler
hat, einen verschränkten Zustand zu transformieren, der mit einem anderen Spieler geteilt wird, und genau zu verstehen,
was diese Freiheit ist,
ist ein wichtiger Schritt beim Verstehen von Quanteninformation, und wir werden genau sehen, wie man diese Freiheit in einfachen
und eleganten Begriffen beschreibt, in der
dritten Einheit der Serie.
Superdense Coding bietet auch
ein konkretes Beispiel dafür, was man mit Verschränkung tun kann, nämlich zwei klassischen
Bits zu ermöglichen, übertragen zu werden,
indem man ein einzelnes qubit sendet. Wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, ist das
nachweislich ohne Verschränkung durch Holevos Theorem nicht möglich.
Wir können auch Teleportation und Superdense Coding zusammen betrachten, und wir sehen, dass sie
eine Äquivalenz begründen
zwischen einem qubit quantenmechanischer Kommunikation und zwei Bits klassischer Kommunikation.
Solange du bereit bist,
ein e-Bit auszugeben, kannst du effektiv
das eine in das andere umwandeln.
Teleportation ermöglicht die
Kommunikation eines qubit mithilfe von zwei klassischen Bits Kommunikation, und Superdense Coding geht in die andere Richtung
und ermöglicht zwei klassische
Bits Kommunikation mithilfe eines qubit quantenmechanischer Kommunikation.
Ohne das e-Bit auszugeben, kannst du jedoch
keines davon in das andere umwandeln – es ist die Verschränkung, die
das möglich macht.
Das dritte und letzte Beispiel,
das wir in dieser Lektion behandeln werden, ist kein Protokoll, sondern ein
Spiel, bekannt als das CHSH-Spiel.
Wenn wir in diesem Kontext von einem Spiel sprechen, meinen wir nicht etwas, das zum
Spaß oder Sport gespielt werden soll,
sondern vielmehr eine mathematische Abstraktion im Sinne der Spieltheorie zum Beispiel.
Mathematische Abstraktionen von Spielen werden sehr häufig in der
Wirtschaft und Informatik untersucht, zum Beispiel, und es gibt
durchaus einen großen Wert
in der Abstraktion zu finden, also sind Spiele nicht alles Spaß
in der Spieltheorie, wie sich herausstellt,
obwohl es Spaß macht, darüber nachzudenken.
In diesem besonderen Fall haben wir im Wesentlichen
ein Gedankenexperiment, das sich auf
ziemlich intuitive Weise als Spiel beschreiben lässt.
Die Buchstaben CHSH beziehen sich auf die Autoren John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony und Richard Holt eines Papiers von 1969,
in dem das Beispiel
erstmals beschrieben wurde. Sie haben es
tatsächlich nicht als Spiel beschrieben, und es ist ziemlich üblich,
auf dieses Beispiel
nicht als CHSH-Spiel, sondern
vielmehr als CHSH-Ungleichung zu verweisen.
Für einen Informatiker wie mich ist es jedoch ganz natürlich,
es als Spiel zu beschreiben.
Ich habe bereits angedeutet, dass
mathematische Abstraktionen von Spielen sowohl wichtig als auch nützlich sind, und es gibt viele verschiedene
Kategorien von Spielen,
die betrachtet werden können. Das CHSH-Spiel ist ein
Beispiel für eine Klasse von Spielen, die als Nicht-lokale Spiele bezeichnet werden.
Hier ist der allgemeine Aufbau
eines Nicht-lokalen Spiels.
Wir haben zwei Spieler, Alice und Bob, die als Team kooperieren, also gewinnen sie entweder gemeinsam
oder verlieren gemeinsam.
Das bedeutet, dass sie keinen
Anreiz haben, eigennützig zu handeln, es ist also im Wesentlichen das entgegengesetzte
Extrem zu Nullsummenspielen,
die rein wettbewerbsorientiert sind; hier ist das Spiel rein kooperativ.
Es gibt eine dritte Instanz, den sogenannten Schiedsrichter.
Der Schiedsrichter ist kein Spieler im Spiel, sondern leitet das Spiel, und du kannst dir die Spezifikation
einer bestimmten Instanz
eines Nicht-lokalen Spiels und die Spezifikation eines
Schiedsrichters als äquivalent vorstellen.
Es gibt eine entscheidend wichtige Einschränkung für Alice und Bob: Sobald das Spiel beginnt, ist es ihnen verboten, miteinander zu kommunizieren.
Sie können sich vorher auf
jede Strategie einigen, die sie möchten, aber während des Spiels selbst ist keine Kommunikation
zwischen ihnen erlaubt.
Wenn du möchtest, kannst du dir
vorstellen, dass das Spiel in einer Art gesicherter Einrichtung stattfindet, als ob der Schiedsrichter die
Rolle eines Detektivs spielt
und Alice und Bob Verdächtige sind, die sich in verschiedenen
Räumen einer Polizeistation befinden – aber eine andere Art,
über den Aufbau nachzudenken,
ist, dass Alice und Bob
durch eine enorme Distanz getrennt sind und Kommunikation verboten ist, weil die Lichtgeschwindigkeit keine Kommunikation
schnell genug ermöglicht. Wenn Alice zum Beispiel versucht, Bob eine
Nachricht zu schicken, ist das Spiel vorbei, bevor
Bob sie empfängt.
Die Funktionsweise eines Nicht-lokalen Spiels
ist die folgende: Zuerst stellt der Schiedsrichter sowohl
Alice als auch Bob eine Frage.
Alices Frage wird mit X bezeichnet und Bobs Frage mit Y.
Im Allgemeinen kannst du dir X und Y als klassische Zustände
aus beliebigen klassischen Zuständen vorstellen, und im
spezifischen Fall des CHSH-Spiels
sind X und Y Bits.
Alice und Bob müssen dann Antworten geben: Alices Antwort wird mit A bezeichnet
und Bobs Antwort mit B.
Auch diese Antworten können allgemein als klassische Zustände betrachtet werden, und wie die Fragen werden sie
im CHSH-Spiel Bits sein.
An diesem Punkt trifft der
Schiedsrichter eine Entscheidung: Alice und Bob gewinnen oder verlieren je nachdem, ob das
Antwortpaar A, B
für das
Fragepaar X, Y, das der Schiedsrichter gestellt hat, als korrekt gilt – dazu werde ich gleich noch etwas mehr sagen.
Zuerst wollen wir uns den
Schiedsrichter genauer ansehen, um zu verstehen, was
für Alice und Bob in einem Nicht-lokalen Spiel potenziell schwierig ist.
Was ein Nicht-lokales Spiel
potenziell herausfordernd macht, ist, dass der Schiedsrichter Zufälligkeit nutzen kann, um die Fragen X und Y zu wählen.
Das bedeutet, dass Alice
und Bob Unsicherheit haben – sie wissen im Voraus nicht, welche Frage ihnen gestellt wird, und vielleicht noch wichtiger:
Sie wissen nicht, welche Frage
der andere erhalten hat – und genau diese Unsicherheit
zusammen mit der Tatsache, dass sie nicht kommunizieren können,
stellt die Herausforderung dar.
Das ähnelt der Situation, in der ein Detektiv
zwei Verdächtige in verschiedenen Räumen verhört – wenn
die Verdächtigen nicht wissen,
welche Fragen dem anderen gestellt werden, ist es für sie viel schwerer, wenn sie schuldig sind, ihre Geschichte konsistent zu halten.
Ich habe vor Kurzem erwähnt, dass der Schiedsrichter eine Entscheidung trifft,
ob Alice und Bob richtig oder falsch
geantwortet haben
abhängig von den Fragen,
die ihnen gestellt wurden.
Es wird angenommen, dass diese
Entscheidung nach einer festen
Regel getroffen wird, und du kannst jede beliebige Regel in Betracht ziehen –
aber was auch immer sie ist:
Es wird angenommen, dass Alice
und Bob die Regel kennen, sodass sie zumindest eine
Chance haben, richtig zu antworten.
Wir werden uns die
Regel für das CHSH-Spiel gleich ansehen, aber wir könnten
eine andere Regel in Betracht ziehen und hätten dann ein anderes
Beispiel für ein Nicht-lokales Spiel.
Manche Nicht-lokalen Spiele sind interessant, und tatsächlich sind einige bis heute ziemlich faszinierend und rätselhaft, und
manche sind nicht so interessant –
das liegt einfach in der Natur
des Nicht-lokalen-Spiel-Modells.
Wie auch immer: Das sind die zwei verschiedenen Dinge, die benötigt werden, um einen Schiedsrichter zu beschreiben – wie genau werden die Fragen ausgewählt
und welche Antwortpaare sind für jedes mögliche Fragepaar korrekt.
Wenn wir eine Beschreibung
dieser zwei Dinge haben, dann haben wir eine Beschreibung des Schiedsrichters, und das beschreibt effektiv
eine Instanz eines Nicht-lokalen Spiels.
Schauen wir uns jetzt
das CHSH-Spiel im Einzelnen an.
Die Art, wie das Spiel
definiert ist, oder gleichwertig, wie der Schiedsrichter definiert ist, lautet wie folgt:
Zuerst sind, wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, die Fragen und Antworten allesamt Bits – der Schiedsrichter sendet also ein Bit X
an Alice und ein Bit Y an Bob,
und beide antworten mit einem Bit. Alice antwortet mit A
und Bob antwortet mit B.
Die Art, wie der Schiedsrichter wählt,
welche Fragen er stellt, ist einfach: Er wählt sie
gleichmäßig zufällig,
d. h., das Fragepaar X, Y hat für jede
der vier Möglichkeiten die gleiche Wahrscheinlichkeit: null, null; null, eins;
eins, null; und eins, eins.
Schließlich ist die Regel, die
bestimmt, welche Antworten gewinnen und welche verlieren, folgende:
Ein Antwortpaar A, B ist für das Fragepaar X, Y korrekt,
genau dann wenn das exklusive Oder von A und B gleich dem logischen Und von X und Y ist.
Das lässt sich vielleicht etwas leichter verdauen, wenn wir diese Bedingungen
in Form einer Tabelle ausdrücken, wie du sie hier siehst.
In der ersten Spalte haben wir die vier möglichen Fragepaare, und in der zweiten Spalte
haben wir die Bedingungen für A und B,
die erforderlich sind, damit
Alice und Bob gewinnen.
In den ersten drei Fällen
ist das Und von X und Y gleich null, sodass das exklusive Oder gleich null sein muss
damit sie gewinnen können,
und das ist dasselbe wie zu sagen, dass A und B gleich sein müssen, weil A und B Bits sind,
und der vierte Fall,
das UND von X und Y ist gleich
eins, und so muss das exklusive Oder von A und B gleich eins sein, damit Alice und Bob gewinnen
und das ist dasselbe
wie zu sagen, dass A und B unterschiedlich sein müssen.
Das ist also das CHSH-Spiel, und jetzt können wir über
verschiedene mögliche Strategien für Alice und Bob nachdenken und wie
gut sie in diesem Spiel abschneiden können.
Fangen wir damit an, über
deterministische Strategien nachzudenken, bei denen Alices Antwort A eine
Funktion der Frage X ist, die sie erhält, und
ebenso ist Bobs Antwort B
eine Funktion der
Frage Y, die er erhält.
Und wie sich herausstellt, kann keine
deterministische Strategie jedes Mal gewinnen.
Eine Möglichkeit, das zu begründen, ist
einfach, alle möglichen
deterministischen Strategien der Reihe nach durchzugehen und zu überprüfen, dass jede einzelne verliert
bei mindestens einem der vier
möglichen Fragepaare.
Alice und Bob haben jeweils
vier mögliche Funktionen zur Auswahl, die haben wir
in Lektion eins gesehen, also gibt es insgesamt 16 Möglichkeiten
zu überprüfen.
Eine andere Möglichkeit, das zu sehen, ist,
die Gleichungen hier auf dem Bildschirm zu betrachten, wir denken
über deterministische Strategien nach
bei denen A und B Funktionen
von X bzw. Y sind.
Also zum Beispiel repräsentiert A von null
Alices Antwort, wenn ihre Frage X gleich null ist, und A von eins repräsentiert Alices Antwort
wenn ihre Frage X gleich eins ist.
Das sind die vier Gleichungen,
die wahr sein müssen, damit die Gewinnbedingungen
in jedem der vier Fälle erfüllt sind.
Wenn zum Beispiel X gleich
null und Y gleich null ist, muss das exklusive Oder von A
und B gleich null sein,
wohingegen in dem Fall, dass X gleich eins und Y gleich eins ist,
das exklusive Oder von A und B gleich eins sein muss.
Eine Möglichkeit zu sehen, dass
es keine Möglichkeit gibt, die Funktionen A und B so zu wählen, dass
alle diese Gleichungen wahr sind, ist einfach, das exklusive Oder
aller Gleichungen zu nehmen.
Das exklusive Oder eines beliebigen
Binärwerts mit sich selbst ist gleich null, und daraus folgt, dass das exklusive Oder
der linken Seiten
gleich null ist, das liegt
daran, dass wir zwei Instanzen von A null, zwei Instanzen von A eins haben,
zwei Instanzen von B null
und zwei Instanzen von B eins.
Wenn wir sie also alle XOR-verknüpfen,
ergibt sich als Endergebnis null, aber wenn wir das exklusive Oder der rechten Seiten der Gleichungen nehmen,
erhalten wir eins, nicht null. Also können die vier Gleichungen
unmöglich alle wahr sein, mindestens eine von ihnen muss falsch sein
und das wird dazu führen, dass
Alice und Bob in mindestens einem der vier Fälle verlieren.
Und daraus folgt, weil der Schiedsrichter die Fragen
gleichmäßig wählt, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit für Alice und Bob, mit
einer deterministischen Strategie zu gewinnen,
höchstens drei Viertel oder 75% beträgt.
Die Tatsache, dass Alice und Bob mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von drei Vierteln gewinnen können, ist eigentlich ganz einfach zu sehen,
wenn Alice und Bob zum Beispiel beide immer null antworten,
werden sie in drei
von vier Fällen richtig liegen.
Alice und Bob können also mit einer
deterministischen Strategie nicht besser als 75% der Zeit gewinnen.
Aber was ist mit einer probabilistischen Strategie?
Nun, es stellt sich heraus, dass eine
probabilistische Strategie ihnen überhaupt nicht hilft, denn jede
probabilistische Strategie
kann alternativ als zufällige Auswahl einer deterministischen Strategie betrachtet werden, genau wie probabilistische
Operationen betrachtet werden können
als zufällige Auswahl von
deterministischen Operationen, wie wir in der ersten Lektion gesehen haben.
Der Durchschnitt ist niemals
größer als das Maximum, also folgt daraus, dass eine
probabilistische Strategie keinen Vorteil beim Gewinnen bietet
gegenüber einer deterministischen Strategie. Das schließt sogar die Möglichkeit ein, dass die zufälligen
Entscheidungen von Alice und Bob korreliert sind.
Also, der Kern der Sache ist, dass mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von drei Vierteln zu gewinnen das Beste ist, was Alice
und Bob mit einer klassischen Strategie tun können,
ob deterministisch
oder probabilistisch.
Die naheliegende Frage, die man sich an diesem Punkt stellen muss, ist, ob Alice und Bob mit einer Quantenstrategie besser abschneiden können,
und insbesondere
wenn sie sich einen verschränkten Quantenzustand teilen, den sie hätten vorbereiten können,
bevor sie das Spiel spielen, kann das ihnen helfen?
Die Antwort ist ja, das kann es, und das ist der Punkt des Beispiels und deshalb ist es so interessant.
Schauen wir uns also genau an, wie
Alice und Bob in diesem Spiel durch Verschränkung besser abschneiden können.
Das Erste, was wir tun müssen, ist, einen Quantenzustandsvektor Chi
theta für jeden Winkel theta zu definieren, wie du hier auf dem Bildschirm sehen kannst.
Chi theta ist also gleich
dem Kosinus theta mal Ket null plus dem Sinus theta mal Ket
eins, und hier übrigens,
denken wir über
Winkel in Bogenmaß nach.
Hier ist zum Beispiel der Vektor, den wir erhalten, wenn theta gleich Pi durch
vier ist, was 45 Grad entspricht.
Kosinus von Pi durch vier
und Sinus von Pi durch vier sind beide gleich eins durch
die Quadratwurzel aus zwei, also ist das nur ein anderer
Name für den Plus-Zustand.
Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel, wenn Theta gleich drei mal Pi durch acht ist, und falls du
den Sinus nicht
und den Kosinus von drei mal Pi durch acht im Kopf hast,
hier ist eine Tabelle der Sinuswerte und Kosinuswerte, die wir
tatsächlich brauchen werden
in diesem Beispiel
und dazu gehören die, die wir für diesen speziellen Vektor brauchen.
Wenn wir nun das innere Produkt zwischen zwei beliebigen dieser Vektoren
für Winkel alpha und beta nehmen wollen, ist das
unkompliziert.
Wir haben nur reelle
Einträge in diesen Vektoren, also gibt es keine komplexen
Konjugierten, um die wir uns kümmern müssen, und wir erhalten das Produkt der Kosinuswerte
plus das Produkt der Sinuswerte, und wir können eine der
sogenannten Winkeladditionsformeln verwenden
um das zu vereinfachen: es ist der
Kosinus der Differenz zwischen den Winkeln, und
weil die Kosinusfunktion
symmetrisch um null ist,
spielt es keine Rolle, in welcher Reihenfolge wir sie nehmen.
Falls du diese trigonometrischen Identitäten
nicht auswendig weißt, bist du
übrigens nicht allein, aber du musst sie dir nicht merken,
du kannst sie einfach nachschlagen. Diese hier ergibt aber Sinn,
wenn du an die geometrische Interpretation
des inneren Produkts denkst
zwischen reellen Einheitsvektoren als Kosinus des Winkels zwischen ihnen.
Wenn wir das innere
Produkt des Tensorprodukts von zwei beliebigen dieser Vektoren
mit dem Phi-plus-Zustand berechnen, erhalten wir einen ähnlichen Ausdruck
außer dass im Nenner eine
Wurzel aus zwei steht.
Dies ist das erste Mal,
dass der Phi-plus-Zustand im Kontext
dieses Beispiels auftaucht, und wir werden genau sehen, warum wir
an diesem speziellen inneren Produkt interessiert sind, aber im Moment wollen wir
nur beobachten, dass wir denselben Ausdruck erhalten, den wir hatten
für das innere Produkt geteilt
durch die Quadratwurzel aus zwei, und so können wir wie zuvor vereinfachen.
Als nächstes definieren wir eine
unitäre Matrix U theta für jeden Winkel theta,
wie du hier siehst,
es ist nicht schwer zu
überprüfen, dass dies tatsächlich eine unitäre Matrix ist.
Das Wichtigste, was wir
erkennen müssen, ist, dass der Vektor si theta orthogonal ist zu
dem Vektor si theta plus Pi durch zwei, und das ergibt Sinn
denn wenn wir um Pi durch zwei, also 90 Grad, drehen,
erhalten wir einen orthogonalen Vektor.
Wenn wir dann U
theta mit U theta dagger multiplizieren, erhalten wir die Identitätsmatrix.
Intuitiv gesprochen
bewirkt diese Matrix als Operation,
si theta auf ket null und si theta plus Pi durch zwei auf ket eins abzubilden.
An diesem Punkt haben wir
alles, was wir brauchen, um Alice und Bobs Strategie zu beschreiben.
Zuerst, genau wie bei der Teleportation und dem Superdense Coding, werden Alice und Bob damit beginnen, ein e-bit zu teilen.
Alice hält ein qubit A,
Bob hält ein qubit B, und zusammen befinden sich die beiden qubits
im Phi-plus-Zustand.
Alice geht wie folgt vor: Sie schaut sich das Bit X an, das
sie vom Schiedsrichter erhält,
und wenn X gleich null ist,
wendet sie U null auf A an, was zufällig dasselbe ist
wie nichts zu tun, weil U null die Identitätsmatrix ist,
wenn X gleich eins ist, wendet sie dagegen U Pi durch vier auf A an.
Nachdem sie eine
der beiden Operationen angewendet hat, misst sie A mit einer
Standardbasismessung und sendet das Ergebnis,
das sie erhält, an den Schiedsrichter.
Bob macht etwas sehr Ähnliches, sein qubit heißt natürlich B, und er erhält Y vom
Schiedsrichter statt X
aber der wesentliche Unterschied ist,
dass er andere Winkel für seine unitären Operationen verwendet.
Wenn Y gleich null ist, wendet er
U Pi durch acht an, und wenn Y gleich eins ist, wendet er U negativ Pi durch acht an.
Und wir werden gleich sehen, warum diese Winkelwahlen gute Wahlen sind,
das ist überhaupt nicht offensichtlich.
Und hier ist ein circuit-Diagramm,
das diese Strategie ausdrückt.
Bob ist oben und Alice
ist diesmal unten, hier ist das e-bit, das hereinkommt
und das sind die unitären
gates, die Alice und Bob anwenden können oder auch nicht,
je nachdem, was X und Y sind.
Bei diesem und jenem haben wir gates, die entweder durch das Bit X oder durch das Bit Y gesteuert werden
und bei diesen beiden hier haben wir, was wie
Control-gates aussieht, außer dass der Kreis nicht ausgefüllt ist.
Und das bedeutet,
dass wenn das Steuerbit auf null gesetzt ist, das gate ausgeführt wird, und wenn das Steuerbit auf
eins gesetzt ist, passiert nichts.
Es ist also genau wie ein
gewöhnliches Control-gate, außer dass die Rollen von null und eins für die Steuerung vertauscht sind.
Effektiv wendet Bob
dieses gate hier an, wenn Y gleich null ist, er
wendet dieses gate hier an
wenn Y gleich eins ist, und ähnlich wendet Alice dieses gate hier
an, wenn X gleich null ist, und dieses gate hier,
wenn X gleich eins ist.
Das ist also Alice und Bobs Strategie, und jetzt müssen wir nur noch
herausfinden, wie gut sie funktioniert.
Für die Analyse der Quantenstrategie, die ich gerade beschrieben habe, brauchen wir
an diesem Punkt wirklich nur zwei Dinge: erstens die
unitäre Matrix U Theta
ist wie du hier siehst, und
zweitens hatten wir diese Formel.
Wir brauchen die Definition des Vektors si theta nicht einmal mehr, diese beiden Gleichungen sind alles, was wir brauchen.
Es gibt vier Fälle zu
betrachten, beginnend mit Fall eins, nämlich dass X gleich
null und Y gleich null ist.
Und wenn wir uns die Strategie noch einmal ansehen, stellen wir fest, dass in diesem
Fall Alice U null auf ihrem qubit ausführt und Bob
U pi durch acht auf seinem qubit ausführt.
Denk daran: Alice ist unten
und Bob ist oben, also sieht der Zustand, den sie
erhalten, so aus.
Und wenn wir das
gemäß der Definition von U theta auseinandernehmen, erhalten wir diesen
Ausdruck, den du hier siehst.
Wir müssen das nicht
weiter auseinandernehmen, weil wir die andere
Formel haben, die uns weiterhilft.
Und wenn wir diese Formel
auf jeden der vier Terme anwenden, erhalten wir das hier.
An diesem Punkt messen Alice und Bob beide, und hier ist eine Tabelle, die
die Verteilung der Ergebnisse erklärt.
Wir nehmen den Betrag
der Koeffizienten zum Quadrat, um die Wahrscheinlichkeiten zu erhalten, was in diesem Fall
zufällig die Quadrate der Koeffizienten sind,
weil die Koeffizienten
in diesem Fall allesamt reelle Zahlen sind.
Wenn wir die
Sinus- und Kosinuswerte von früher in der Lektion
zusammen mit einigen Symmetrien verwenden, können wir diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten
so ausdrücken, wie wir es hier haben
in der letzten Spalte.
Jetzt ist das, was uns wirklich interessiert,
die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie gewinnen, und denk daran: In dem Fall, dass X und Y beide null sind,
gewinnen sie, wenn A und B gleich sind, und sie verlieren, wenn A und B nicht gleich sind.
Wenn wir diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten berechnen, stellen wir fest, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass A und B gleich sind, die Summe dieser Zahl und dieser Zahl ist,
was gleich zwei plus
Wurzel zwei alles durch vier ist, was ungefähr 85 % sind.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass A und B nicht gleich sind, ist zwei minus Wurzel zwei alles durch vier, was natürlich eins minus der Größe ist,
die wir gerade berechnet haben, also
gewinnen sie in diesem Fall mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von etwa 85 %.
Es gibt noch drei weitere Fälle zu betrachten, aber sie sind alle diesem hier sehr ähnlich.
In dem Fall, dass X gleich
null und Y gleich eins ist, wendet Bob U negativ pi durch acht an, anstatt U pi durch acht,
die Werte in den
Formeln ändern sich etwas, aber wir erhalten am Ende genau
dieselben Wahrscheinlichkeiten wie im vorherigen Fall.
Wenn X gleich null und Y gleich eins ist, gewinnen Alice und Bob immer noch,
wenn A und B gleich sind, und wir haben also genau die
gleiche Gewinnwahrscheinlichkeit
wie zuvor.
Im dritten Fall, wenn X gleich eins und Y gleich null ist, haben wir
eine ähnliche Situation: Die Winkel sind unterschiedlich,
aber sie haben genau
dieselbe Beziehung
zueinander, und tatsächlich erhalten wir genau den
gleichen Vektor wie im vorherigen Fall.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind also dieselben, und so auch die Gewinnwahrscheinlichkeit.
Der letzte Fall ist etwas
anders, wie wir vielleicht erwarten würden, weil die Gewinnbedingung
in diesem Fall anders ist.
Wenn X und Y beide gleich eins sind, gewinnen Alice und Bob, wenn
A und B unterschiedlich sind.
Die grundlegende Methode ist dieselbe, obwohl die Winkel unterschiedlich sind; diesmal erhalten wir diesen Vektor hier
und du kannst das überprüfen, indem du die erforderlichen Subtraktionen durchführst.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeiten ändern sich schließlich doch, und wenn wir die Werte nachschlagen, die wir benötigen, sehen wir, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
effektiv
ihre Positionen von vorher getauscht haben, sodass diesmal die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass A nicht gleich B ist, die größere der beiden ist,
aber das ist gut, weil Alice und Bob in diesem Fall gewinnen, wenn
A und B nicht gleich sind.
Also gewinnen sie erneut mit
einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von ungefähr 85 %.
Da sie in jedem
Fall mit derselben Wahrscheinlichkeit gewinnen, nämlich zwei plus Wurzel zwei
alles durch vier oder etwa 85 %,
ist das die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass sie insgesamt gewinnen.
Das ist besser als jede klassische Strategie bei diesem Spiel es kann, und das ist
es, was es interessant macht.
Dies ist die
optimale Gewinnwahrscheinlichkeit für jede Quantenstrategie: Man
kann es mit keinem verschränkten Zustand besser machen als das.
Diese Tatsache ist als Tsirelson-Ungleichung bekannt, sie ist nach Boris
Tsirelson benannt, der sie als Erster bewiesen hat, und soweit ich weiß, war er einer der Ersten,
der dieses Beispiel als Spiel beschrieben hat. Falls die Analyse,
die wir gerade durchgegangen sind, ein wenig geheimnisvoll erscheint,
ist es möglich, darüber
geometrisch nachzudenken, was hilfreich sein könnte,
um dir ein besseres Gefühl für die Wahl der Winkel zu geben.
Wenn wir insbesondere die
Formel verwenden, die du hier siehst, die wir leicht aus den Ausdrücken ableiten können,
die wir bereits für die
beteiligten inneren Produkte gefunden haben, dann können wir alternativ
die Wahrscheinlichkeiten der verschiedenen möglichen
Messergebnisse ausdrücken
in den vier Fällen wie folgt: Wenn X, Y gleich null, null ist, dann sind das die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
der verschiedenen Messergebnisse, und du musst entweder zurückdenken oder zurückblicken auf die Analyse,
die wir gerade durchgegangen sind, um zu schlussfolgern, dass wir unsere Formel verwenden.
Hier können wir die
verschiedenen Zustandsvektoren sehen, wie sie zuvor gezeichnet wurden, und die Farbcodierung hier
ist, dass Blau
dem Ergebnis null entspricht und Rot
dem Ergebnis eins entspricht.
Man kann sehen, dass der Winkel
zwischen den blauen Vektoren und der Winkel zwischen den roten
Vektoren relativ klein ist,
er beträgt in beiden Fällen pi durch acht, sodass der Kosinus relativ groß ist, und das bedeutet, dass die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die beiden Ergebnisse
gleich sind, ist verhältnismäßig groß.
Im Fall, dass X, Y gleich null, eins ist, ist es eine ähnliche Situation – der
Winkel zwischen den Vektoren gleicher Farbe ist klein,
sodass die Wahrscheinlichkeit
gleicher Ergebnisse wieder verhältnismäßig groß ist.
Der dritte Fall ist ähnlich, und im vierten Fall,
wenn X, Y gleich eins, eins ist, passiert etwas Interessantes –
diesmal, rein durch die Art und Weise,
wie diese Vektoren gewählt wurden, sehen wir, dass die Winkel zwischen
Vektoren gleicher Farbe
verhältnismäßig groß sind, und konkret betragen die Winkel jeweils dreimal
pi über acht in beiden Fällen.
Das bedeutet, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass die Messergebnisse gleich sind, verhältnismäßig klein ist, aber das ist der eine Fall,
in dem Alice und Bob gewinnen,
wenn ihre Antworten sich unterscheiden –
das ist also genau das, was wir wollen.
Noch einmal zur Übersicht, hier sind die Vektoren: wenn X, Y gleich null, null ist,
wenn X, Y gleich null, eins ist,
wenn X, Y gleich eins, null ist,
und wenn X, Y gleich eins, eins ist.
Und vielleicht hilft dieses geometrische
Bild dabei, ein gewisses Gefühl dafür zu entwickeln,
wie diese Strategie funktioniert,
und warum diese verschiedenen Winkel so gewählt wurden, wie sie gewählt wurden.
Zum Abschluss der Lektion möchte ich noch einige kurze
Anmerkungen zum CHSH-Spiel machen.
Zunächst: Wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, wird dieses Beispiel nicht immer
als Spiel beschrieben.
In der Physik-Community zum Beispiel ist es üblicher, dass
das Beispiel einfach als Experiment beschrieben wird, nicht als Spiel,
und Alice und Bob
werden eher als Detektoren denn als Spieler betrachtet.
Die Grundidee eines solchen Experiments, bei dem Verschränkung zu
statistischen Ergebnissen führt, die mit keiner
klassischen Beschreibung vereinbar sind,
oder allgemeiner mit keiner
Theorie, die auf sogenannten lokalen verborgenen Variablen basiert,
geht auf John Bell zurück, den Namensgeber der Bell-Zustände.
Daher bezeichnen Menschen
Experimente dieser Art oft als Bell-Tests.
Manchmal spricht man auch
vom Bell'schen Theorem, das auf verschiedene Weisen formuliert werden kann, aber im Wesentlichen besagt,
dass die Quantenmechanik
nicht mit sogenannten Theorien lokaler verborgener Variablen vereinbar ist.
Das CHSH-Spiel oder die CHSH-Ungleichung ist im Grunde ein sehr schönes und klares
Beispiel für einen Bell-Test,
und du kannst dieses Beispiel
als Beweis oder Demonstration des Bell'schen Theorems betrachten.
Die zweite Anmerkung ist, dass das CHSH-Spiel uns eine Möglichkeit bietet, experimentell zu testen, ob die Theorie der Quanteninformation
eine genaue Theorie ist. Wir können tatsächlich Experimente aufbauen, die das CHSH-Spiel implementieren,
einschließlich der Art von
Strategie, die auf Verschränkung basiert und die ich gerade beschrieben habe,
und schauen, ob sie funktioniert – und das tut sie.
Das gibt uns ein hohes Maß
an Vertrauen, dass Verschränkung real ist, und anders als die vielleicht
vagen oder poetischen Versuche,
Verschränkung zu erklären,
gibt uns das CHSH-Spiel oder -Experiment eine konkrete
und überprüfbare Möglichkeit, Verschränkung zu beobachten.
Falls das wichtig klingt –
das ist es, und der Nobelpreis für Physik 2022
bestätigt genau das.
Der Preis wurde vergeben an
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, das „C" in CHSH, und Anton Zeilinger,
für Experimente mit verschränkten Photonen, die den Verstoß
gegen Bell-Ungleichungen nachwiesen, oder mit anderen Worten, die zeigten, dass Quantenstrategien
der Art, die ich beschrieben habe, tatsächlich funktionieren und klassische Strategien übertreffen.
Und wenn du daran interessiert bist,
mehr darüber zu erfahren, empfehle ich dir, das
Video über Bells Theorem von meiner Kollegin Olivia Lanes anzuschauen,
hier auf dem Qiskit YouTube-Kanal.
Und schließlich ist das Thema
nicht-lokaler Spiele im Allgemeinen wirklich faszinierend, und es ist
ein aktives Forschungsgebiet,
das Physik, Informatik
und reine Mathematik vereint, und es gibt noch viele
interessante Fragen
zu nicht-lokalen Spielen, die
bis heute unbeantwortet geblieben sind.
Und damit ist Lektion vier zu Ende, ebenso wie
Einheit eins der Reihe über die Grundlagen der Quanteninformation.
Die erste Lektion erklärte,
wie Quanteninformation für einzelne Systeme in Isolation funktioniert, und die zweite Lektion erklärte,
wie Quanteninformation
für mehrere Systeme funktioniert,
was sich recht natürlich daraus ergibt, wie es für einzelne Systeme funktioniert.
Die dritte Lektion führte
das Quantum-circuit-Modell der Berechnung ein, und in der vierten Lektion haben wir uns drei wichtige Beispiele angeschaut,
die veranschaulichen, was wir
mit Verschränkung tun können.
Dabei haben wir einige sehr wichtige mathematische Konzepte kennengelernt,
darunter Tensorprodukte und innere Produkte, und wir haben
einige grundlegende Grenzen
der Quanteninformation beobachtet.
Ich hoffe, du bist bei der
nächsten Einheit der Reihe dabei, die sich mit Quantenalgorithmen befassen wird, wo wir uns auf die Frage konzentrieren,
welche rechnerischen Vorteile
die Quanteninformation bietet.
Bis dahin, auf Wiedersehen.